[Müzik]
Merhabalar
Ben bir malım Gerçekten şimdi aklınıza
ilk olarak şu geliyor ya burası teleks
bir sürü para verdiniz hepiniz bir malı
dinlemek için miydi Bütün bunlar
maalesef En azından bir kısmını beni
dinlemek için verdiniz ve bunun için
içtenlikle hepinizden özür diliyorum
Biraz sonra anlatırım her şey için özür
diliyorum Çünkü biraz sonra anlatacağım
şeyler sizi mutlu etmeyecek mutsuz
edecekler ama ben şunu inanıyorum hocam
hayatın gerçekleri mutsuzluk getirse de
çok motive edici kimse bunlardan
bahsetmiyor olsa da Dolayısıyla ben size
bunlardan bahsedeceğim Ben bir
akademisyenim ve gerçekten bu işi çok
severek ve çok isteyerek yapıyorum
ama biraz sonra sizlere anlatacağım şey
akademisyen olmamın pırıl pırıl
başarılarla dolu motivasyon hikayesi
değil pislik içerisindeki çamura
bulanmış gerçek hikayesini anlatacağım
sizlere dedim ya bir malım diye ilk önce
ben bana anlatan her şeyi inandım Hocam
bu kişisel gelişim seminerleri vardı
kitapları vardı okuyordum hepsine
gidiyordum katılıyordum ve hep şey var
diyor 3 aşağı 5 yukarı diyorlardı ki
yeter ki iste Eğer bir şey çok istersen
ve Çok çalışırsan kimse önünde engel
olamaz Steve Jobs mu olmak istiyorsun
Bill Gates mi olmak istiyorsun elin mas
mı olmak istiyorsun olursun Hocam kimse
önünde engel olamaz diyorlardı Ben de
inandım ve çok çalıştım sonra hayata
atıldım Ama hayatın gerçekleri şöyle
değildi
bu Bill Gates zaten tanıyorsunuz eminim
ki bu da Bill Gates hocam 1970'li
yıllarda gitmiş olduğu dax Lisesinin
bilgisayar laboratuvarı hocam 1970'li
yıllarda bırakın bir liseyi dünyanın
önde gelen birçok Üniversitesinin
bilgisayar laboratuvarı falan yoktu ama
Bill Gates'in gittiği lisenin böyle bir
laboratuvar olanağı vardı tek olanabun
muydu Hayır yine kendi anlatımdan hocam
bir giysin ergenlik dönemleri her ergen
gibi her şeyi isyan ediyor Yeter diyor
baba baba ben okumayacağım diyor Bu ne
biçim kırmızı diyor gökyüzü niye mavi
diyor her şeyi İsyan halinde bilgi etsin
annesi ve babası bir araya geliyorlar bu
çocuğun bu sorunu nasıl çözeriz diye
düşünüyorlar ve bölgenin en ünlü
psikologlarından bir tanesine bilyesi
götürüyorlar Bill Gates şöyle anlatıyor
olayı ya diyor benim için Ufuk açıcı bir
şeydi olaylara bambaşka bir açıdan
bakmaya başladım artık
hocam 1970 yıllara gitmeye gerek yok
2020'li yıllardayız aynı şey bu
yaşınızda siz yapın bir ergen gibi eve
gidin Naz yapmaya başlayın her şey
bağırır Baba ben okumayacağım deyin ben
işi bırakıyorum deyin Bu ne biçim
tarhana çorbası anne diye devirinç
çorbayı nasıl bir tedavi alırdınız Ben
size söyleyeyim hocam büyük bir çoğunuz
için tedavi şöyle olurdu Bir sabrederdi
Babanız 2 sabrederdi 5 sabrederdi sonra
derdi ki Hanım Sen bir içeri geç de ben
bu çocuğun derdini bir çözeyim sonra şu
Avcı hazırlardı Hocam şöyle bir
yapıştırırdı alırdın Tokatı o imelenme
ile bir odaya giderdi düşünürdün sonra
çıkardın tarhana çorbanı içerken derdin
ki baba Allah razı olsun ya sayende
olabilir bambaşka bir açıyla bakmayı
öğrendim artık yepyeni bir açıyla
bakıyorum
bakacağım 1970'li yıllarda Bill Gates'in
aldı ergenlik tedavisi sizin bu
yaşınızda aldığınız depresyon
tedavisinden çok çok daha iyiydi ama
sonra bize diyorlar ki yeter ki iste
olursun dünyayı değiştirecek fikirler mi
üretirsin Elmas mı olmak istiyorsun
olursun be abi hocam elim baskın babası
Zümrüt madeni ile özel jetini takas
etmiş bir adam benim babamla hayatım
boyunca yaptığım en değerli biliyor
musunuz
Malatya'nın kuru kayısı tabağı meşhurdur
Şimdi bunu yiyince şöyle bir şey olmuyor
biliyorsunuz Yani dünyada eşleşecek
fikirler falan üretemiyorsunuz bu melek
yersiniz hocam ishal yapıyor ya Bunun
hepsini ye ertesi gün tuvalete girersin
24 saat fayanslara bakarsın böyle ya
Neden böyle oldu Dersin
olmakları eşit değil ama hikayeleri
Sanki her şey çok eşleşmiş ve çok
parlakmış gibi anlatılıyor bize Ama
gerçekten ne yazık ki bunlar değil
Elbette aklınıza şu geliyor olabilir ya
Bill Gates'in gittiği Liseye giden
Herkes mi bilgisi oldu Herkes mi çok
başarılı oldu Hayır olmadı hocam eminim
ki bir sürede başarısız vardır ama gelin
Gerçekleri konuşalım Eğer ev bakarken
kiralık ev alt katta ve üst katta başka
bir ev olsun Bizimki ara katı olsun da
onlar doğalgazı yaksınlar Biz de Böylece
daha az fatura ödeyelim diye düşünen bir
ailede yetiştirirseniz belli ki belli
olmakta sahip değilsiniz ve Belli ki
Bill Gates olabilme olasılığınız size
anlatılanlar çok daha küçük yine
aklınıza şu geliyor olabilir ya başarılı
olan bütün insanlar mı çok iyi
olanaklara sahipler daha Hayır
değillerdi Aziz Sancar Yani gerçekten
çok dar madde olarak da sahip bir ailede
Büyümüş ama büyük paşaları imza atmış
bir insan ya da çekme severiz Ali
Baba'nın kurucusu ama çok ufak olan
haklara sahip bir ailede yine çıkmış ve
Muazzam başkaları imza atmış Ali Koç Koç
Ailesi ya zenginler laf sokmalar
yapamıyorum böyle bir o gün var Evet
hocam bu insanlar varlar ama aynı bize
anlatılan Hani bu şey Haberler olur ya
Çoban ÖSS'de yks'de şimdi derece yaptı
Aynı onun gibiler varlar ordalar
gerçekler ama gerçekten çok ufak bir
kısmı var gerçeğin geri kalanı büyük
kısmını kimse nedense kolay kolay bize
anlatmıyor Eğer gerçekleri görmek
istiyorsak hocam elde etmemiz gereken
istatistik kaç Çoban üniversite okumak
istedi kaç çoba üniversite sınavına
girebildi ve kaç tane Çoban üniversiteyi
kazanabildi işte O istatistiklerde
gerçekleri görmeye başlayacak maalesef
elimizde doğrudan çobanların üniversite
başarısına dair bir liste yok ama başka
başarı istatistikleri var mesela hocam
İşletmeleri ele alırsak ve işletmelerin
başarısını Sadece 5 yıl boyunca ayakta
kalmaktan ibaret düşünürsek bunu
yapabilen işletme sayısı oranı sadece
%20'den ibaret %80'i batıyor 10 lira
çıkardığımızdan itibaren %10'a düşüyor
hocam
Eğer başarı bireyler bazında alırsak
işler çok daha kötü bireyler için olayı
da doğduğumuz sosyal ekonomik sınavın
sadece bir tık üzerine çıkmak olarak ele
alırsak oranın sadece %7
%93'ümüz doğduğumuz sosyal ekonomik
sınıfın bir üzerine çıkamadan ölüp
gideceğiz
Dolayısıyla hocam ortada Büyük bir yalan
var bize kimse bu gerçekleri anlatmıyor
istisnai başarı hikayeleri her yerde ama
milyarların dünya çapında yaşadığı
Mehmet'in Osman'ın Ayşe'nin yaşadığı
başarısız Hayat hikayelerini kimse bize
anlatmıyor ama onlar da varlar ama
yanlış anlaşılmasın bu motivasyon
hikayeleri çok güzel kesinlikle motive
edici Özgüven kazandırıcı harekete
geçirici ama Gerçeklerden bizi belli
oranda kopartıyorlar hem de sorgulamamız
gereken bazı şeyleri sorgulayamaz hale
getiriyoruz mesela hocam olanaklar eşit
değil ama başarı herkes için tanımlanmış
durumda
kimi çocuklar en iyi liselere gidiyorlar
en güzel yabancı dili öğreniyorlar takım
çalışmasında öğreniyor sorgulamayı
matematiği robotik kodlama öğreniyorlar
Hocam şimdi çocukta ise bunların
hiçbirine sahip değil En fazla takım
çalışmasını Bir Başka arkadaşının apış
arasına kafasını koydu o uzun eşek
konumda öğreniyor burada susuz hocam
görüyorum tek bir çift mi o düşünceler
onlarla takım çalışması öğrenmeye
çalışan çocuklar sonra bu çocuğa da bu
çocuğa Diyoruz ki başarı eşit
tanımlanmış durumda başarı ne Ceo olmak
inanılmaz başarıları elde etmek zengin
olmak hocam ama şartlar eşit değil niye
bunu eşit tanımlıyoruz oraları
karıştırma diyorlar bize hiç oraları sen
şey yapma dert etme devam et
maalesef kötü haber demeniz bitmedi az
önce verdiğim o istatistikler var ya
işte onlar Amerika Birleşik
Devletleri'nde Dolayısıyla doğduğumuz
coğrafyaya göre büyük ihtimalle daha
düşük olma olasılıkla da oldukça fazla
mesela hocam Bill Gates Amerika
seattle'da değil de Türkiye'de
Osmaniye'de Kadirli'de olsaydı
akademisyen olmak isteseydi neler
yaşardı Ben size bir özetleyeyim ama
yanlış anlaşılmasın Bill Gates kadar
kapasitesi falan olduğunu düşünmüyorum
ben malım Buna da yürekten inanıyorum Bu
arada hakikaten
ama işlerinden bir tanesini çok
memiyorum hocam 17 başvurum 17 başvurumu
şöyle bir özellik var 3 kadro birden
açılmış aynı bölümde aynı üniversitede
Bu demek ki Mülakatta ikinci bile olsam
alınacak 3 bile olsa alınacağım demek
çok fazla şansım var çalıştım mülakata
gittim mülakat toplantı odasında 11 kişi
bekliyoruz hazır bir şekilde sonra
kapıdan birisi girdi Asuman üzerinde
eşofmanla girdi eşofmanda oturdu Sonra
kapıda üniversitenin genel sekreteri
geçti ve Osman şöyle yaptı Aa dedi
babişko
Biz o anda 11 kişi dedi ki Bu nasıl
adaletsizlik ya genel sekreterin kızını
alacaksınız yeter böyle şey olmaz İsyan
çıkardık ortalığı yer ayırdık
hocam böyle bir şey olmadı size ben
gerçekleri anlatacağım orada olsanız 11
kişinin gözünde ne gördünüz biliyor
musunuz
işsizliğin çaresizliğini gördünüz kimse
öyle İsyan falan etmedi herkesi Gözde
şey var Tamam bir kadronla mı dedi ki
kadro var Belki birisi Bize düşer hala
herkes kafasından mülakat soruları falan
geçiriyordu mülakata girdim çıktım sonra
sonuçları beklemeye başladım sonuçları
açıklandı bir baktım tek bir kişi
kazanmış
babuşka asma diye Hiçbirimiz kadroya
gayet görülmemişiz Peki olay niye böyle
Çünkü Babişko asumanımız her bir kadro
için en yüksek 4 puan şarj alacağı için
ilk dörde giremiyor Bu nedenle Kadri 3
tane birden çıkartıyorlar ki 12 olarak
en azından mülakata girsin ve müthiş
başarılarıyorlarsın
şu şekilde alındı
benim 10 yıl çalışmam bir babişka
asmanın boş başrol olduğu bir oyunda
tiyatro oyunda arkadaki dekor olmaktan
ibaretti Bunu fark ettim ve gerçekten
hocam samimiyetle söylüyorum eğer ertesi
gün kalktım hüngür hüngür Ağlayarak ben
ders çalışmaya devam ettim niye çok
çalışırsam olur diye mi o hikayede
dinlenmeye bırakmıştım Zaten başka çarem
yoktu başka çarem ondan önce hosting de
Ankara Sanayi yerleri istiyordum kutu
falan yapıyordum o işin bana göre
olmadığını biliyordum akademisyenliği
istiyordum Evet çok çalışmıştım hak
ettiğimi de düşünüyordum ama olmuyordu
bir şekilde ama çalışmada devam etmek
zorundaydım ve şanslıydım ÖYP denilen
bir sistem çıktı herhangi bir mülakata
girmeden sadece puanlarımızla
akademisyen olabiliyordum ve ben de
akademisyenliğe giriş yaptım Böylece
dedim ya ben mesela seviyorum sevdiğim
için de böyle makaleleri okuyorum
üretmeye çalışıyorum arkadaşlarım geldi
Der Oğlum dediler Mal mısın ayın 15'inde
hepimizin maaşı yatıyor Sen niye bu
kadar kasıyorsun Ayrıca bu kadar çok
çalışırsan dikkat çekersin Daha
sonrasında Güney Kore ekme şansım oldu
Doktor sırası araştırmalar yapmak için
istatistik analizleri öğrendim birçok
insan bunu öğrenemiyor ya da öğrenirken
zorlanıyor ve daha sonra piyasaya para
kaptırıyor Ben dedim ki ben bunu YouTube
videolarında anlatayım her bildiğimi
bedava bir şekilde arkadaşlarım geldiler
Onda da böyle bir şey yapma Mal mısın
başlangıcında anlat Geri kalan
danışmanlık Ver parayı dediler Daha
sonra Amerika'ya gitme şansım oldu
doktora sonrası araştırmalar için orada
bir baktım üniversitede bütün sistemi
temelinde Liyakat var Liyakat sayısı
çatır çatır işliyor bilim
üretebiliyorlar dedim ben bundan
bahsetmeliyim YouTube kanalındaki
videolarda tamamiyle yakaklardan
bahsetmeye başladım arkadaşlarım
geldiler oğlum dediler Mal mısın Ne
yapıyorsun başına bela alacaksın kanal
inanılmaz dikkat çekti hocam
100.200-300.400-500'e kadar gitti dedim
bu YouTube'un tek kurşun cebimize
atlayacağız hepsini bağışlayacağız
arkadaşlarım geldi dedim dur dedim dur
ya ben malım ben %100 olarak Hocam
gerçekten buna yürekten inanıyorum ama
size çok güzel bir haberim var Sizler
buradaki insanlar
büyük bir çoğunuz evet Sizler de
malsınız
para vermişsiniz bir şeyler öğreneceğiz
diye bugünkü toplumsal bakış açımızda bu
sistemde Bunlar mallıktan ibaret
cezalarınızı zamanda mı ödüyorsunuz
malsınız hocam 2-3 yılda bir af çıkıyor
ödediğinizde kalırsınız İşe girerken
torpil falan bulmak yerine bileğinizi
hakkıyla mı girmeye çalışıyorsunuz
malsınız Hocam herkesi işe girer
arkandan böyle bakarsınız iş yerine
girdiğiniz yükselmek için Adana verileri
yalakalı kullanmak yerine gece gündüz
çalışma ve alıntınız mı Kullanmak
istiyorsunuz malsınız hocam herkes
yükselir arkalarında ne sallarsınız
Peki ne yapıyoruz Hocam biz ne yapıyorum
ben hakikaten Ben bu soruyu o kadar çok
kendime sordum ki ne yapıyorum Ben
başımı alıp böyle alacak işlerle
uğraşıyorum ben dursam Profesör oluyorum
zaten abi keyfime bakayım ayın 15'inde
dakikada maaşım yatıyor ama sonra Şunu
fark ettim Ben makale okurken yazarken
çok zevk alıyorum hele torpili hiçbir
videolar çekiyorum Ya bu beni inanılmaz
satmıyor diyor ben çok şanslıyım Çünkü
hayatta tutkuyla yapacağım o şeyleri
bulmuş gerçekten çok büyük bir şans
Çünkü hayatın olağan akışında bize
sunulmuş standart çerçevede başarı
hikayeleri var hepimiz oraya koşuyoruz
Hiçbirimiz Gerçekten ne isteyip ne
istemediğini düşünce vakti bile
bulamıyoruz
o başarıya ulaşma olasınız o kadar düşük
ki aslında gerçekte olanağı olmayanlar
için o başarılı gerçekten çok zor işler
Ama bu size yüreklendirmemezlik yapmasın
devam etmek gerekiyor bir şekilde ama
işin gerçeğini de bu da var ne yazık Bir
de her yerde istisnai başarı hikayeleri
Bir de sosyal medya var Herkes çok
başarılı zannediyoruz herkes oralara
ulaşıyor zannediyor sosyal medyada çok
mutlu herkes en güzel yerlerde herkesi
patronu övüyor bir kişiyi gördünüz mü
hocam cumartesi günü patronundan azar
işittikten sonra eve gitsin Survivor
izlerken soğumuş ekşi mandalina yerken
Instagram'da atsın görmüyoruz hocam
bunları Bu yüzden de herkes çok başarılı
zannediyoruz
Maalesef öyle bir gerçek Öyle bir dünya
yok bu dünyada başarısızlık da var ve
olağan Bunu kabullenmek gerekiyor ama
size bu sefer gerçekten güzel bir
haberim var
Bir de başarısızlık yerinde sürecin
kendisine aktarabilirsek yani o yolun
kendisine o da alabilirsek eğer o yolun
sonunda yürüsek yürüsek ve başarısız
olsak bile dönüp baktığımızda pişman
olmayız İyi ki bu yolda yürümüşüm deriz
bizim yapmamız gereken bu hocam ozanna
olmayanlar için tek gerçek bu gerçekten
severek tutkuyla yapacağız O şey Her
neyse onu bulmak ve o yolda yürümek
Ancak bu şekilde o ömrünün sonunda
pişmanlık değil iyi ki yapmışım deme
şansımız olur
[Alkış]
Bunlar Babişko Asuman ürünleri hocam
kalemi var bardağı var oyunu var hepsi
tamamen ücretsiz Bu arada para falan
almıyoruz yanlış anlaşılmasın ürün
satmaya gelmedim ben de yapmadım hiç onu
gönüllerimiz yaptılar kendi emekleriyle
tutkuyla yaptılar Amacımız ne amacımız
100 yıllardır bu coğrafyanın işte
işlemiş olun o torpil binasını söküp
atmak gelecek nesilleri bunu yapmak
zorundayız Dolayısıyla ben hocam sonunda
%100 başarısız olacağım bir yolda
yürüyorum yüzde yüz hocam Yürüyeceğim
yürüyeceğim ve Ömrümün sonuna doğru
anlayacağım ki kaybettim başarısız oldum
Ama şunu biliyorum O gün geldiğinde
dönüp arkama baktığımda iyi ki yapmışım
diyeceğim
Burası hocam LX Sait Lisesi 1970
yılındaki bilgisayar laboratuvarı
bu ise Adana Kadirli
aşağıda gördüğünüz bir özel Jet en
ucuzunu Bugün almaya kalksanız hocam 2
milyon dolar
bu ise Pütürge'nin meşhur kayısı tabağı
en pahalısını almaya kalksanız hocam
sıfırı bugün 732 TL
ama yeter ki inanın isteyin ve çok
çalışın çok çalışır ve isterseniz siz de
bir bilgi edin Elon musk Steve Jobs
olabilirsiniz bir malı dinlediniz
teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]